ich weiß ich alles brennt geht aus am
brett ich hab einfach den ganzen wald
angezündet was hast du total toll
gemacht ich bin glaube ich ja schon fast
am also hier ist mir zu gefährlich das
hier ist mir da ist das was wir machen
hallo ich meine lieben freund und
herzlich willkommen zurück zu einer
weiteren folge minecraft waro auf dem
wasser war zusammen mit den kilos sollen
wir haben gesagt wir teil des jetzt mal
ein wenig auf das heißt ich baue hier
ein wenig zucker an und keynotes ist da
wo er immer ist und zwar unter der erde
ich brauche 50 ist sie schon was ich am
anfang die folgen die sie eigentlich
kein wasser ich pack jetzt erstmal die
lava hier bei uns im laden stimmt stimmt
stimmt das ist wirklich das ist was wir
bisher vernahm dass sie kamen bei der
inzwischen jeder in minecraft pvp mit
flinten stil spielt und lagern
wir müssen unbedingt in unserem inventar
jeder einen wassereimer machst du das
mal bitte du hast oben genug eisen
glaube ich dafür da nach mal in eine
lange das alles klarzumachen
das wäre dass das das wäre super weil
nicht dass wir man hat ja bei seinen
diversen beruf gesehen dass es aber
tatsächlich noch ein problem ist und wir
wollen ja nicht dass unser also wenn
wenn wir sterben allgemein in marokko
also muss jetzt sagen wir haben wir
haben ja unsere also auch unsere
persönlichen erwartungen was
produktivität und so angeht übertroffen
aber wenn wir sterben und ich wir müssen
dich sagen wir werden pvp mega der
schutz sein und sowieso gut ausgesehen
aber das heißt ja nicht zwingen was aber
wenn wir sterben dann ihren haft und
nicht irgendwie so im wasser ertrinken
oder sowas das finde ich ein bisschen
schade für für all die arbeit ich
mindestens mein gegner einmal hinten
bevor er mich umbringen links einmal
berührt wie ein treffer landen und dann
ist auch schon wieder okay damit ist das
aber doch meine mami von mir macht deine
mami auch plakate wenn du aufgibst die
steht neben dran bei mir
die staatsbürger so richtig vor oben ja
ja ich und die länder vom fenster genau
genau das ist ein balkon balco und da
steht dann immer dran und und manchmal
wird sie auch mit stickern was ein
bisschen komisch nächsten acht jahre
nichts zu essen das hat mir schon da bin
ich direkt mit erbgut ist ja ja ist gut
dass das unterleib wasser aufgehört
conny ist es schön dass meine gute sagt
ich freue mich für dich du bist ja ein
richtiger richtiger spitzwegerich wo ich
habe eine riesige ich hab' ich habe eine
ich habe eine höhle gefunden glaube ich
habe da mal rein
ich habe immer angst dass ich die das
einzige was uns ja von mobs herr hier
ist auch obsidian das einzige was uns
vom mops herr richtig gefährlich werden
kann
hier dingens hexen hexen sind richtig
bitter böse so ich hab drei wasser ich
habe dreimal gemacht das heißt wir haben
dann drei wassereimer und dann ja das
mit der lover lasse ich mir gar nicht
erst bieten hier ist es zwar wasser
direkt nebendran aber die mache ich
komplett zu da auch mal was der doppelte
gefunden hat wenn du diamanten gefallen
das ist nicht normal
ich weiß nicht mal wieder schön 22 die
aus 1 gesagt so wie sich das gehört mein
freund ist ja okay dass du bist einfach
die selten das tryp mein typ
obwohl obwohl dankeschön dankeschön das
ist sehr sehr sehr süß von dir und du
kümmerst dich darum was du was du in
hier wohnen die gemacht hast was damals
mein befehl war ja du kümmerst dich um
die um die versorgung ja du ich bin
dabei ich mache es gerade bildungsgrad
erstmal hier schöne wasser einmal
gemacht kann nach oben wenn nur ein
rasenfeld hat uns auch mal ich werde mal
ich weiß wie viel gold wir haben aber
gold äpfel die hat ja patrick auch
benutzt sind anscheinend ziemlich cool
also da kann ich auch mal klar wenn wenn
das irgendwie geht dann macht man mal
welche während ich hier mal die bücher
zum be back klatsche ja immer immer
angst wenn ich an lava bundesbank keine
fakten ergibt keinen sinn
ich glaube hier könnten ins bonner sein
ich weiß es nicht und das ist sehr schön
ich wollte einfach mal alleine dein auto
kaputt ich hab so angst neben aber all
das ist nicht mehr normal
es ist nicht mehr normal wie möglich
vorlage ab vor allem weil so ein projekt
das ist übel so ich baue ich baue alles
bis auf aus eigentlich einfach komplett
zu sodass ihnen drei fliegen kann
jetzt hab ich jetzt schon keine steine
mehr übrig ich brauche so zu dass wir
uns da lager holen können okay aber dass
ich halte ich rein flüchtig das ist gut
so ich habe uns jetzt la vella einmal
wasser
teilweise macht du brauchst du noch
irgendwelche werkzeuge weil ich mache
ein lächeln ja du kannst immer kann es
immer einen kleinen vorrat und
spitzhacken der ist immer sinnvoll
ich bin ich gerade eine höhle ist ein
bisschen spannungsgeladen hier
ausnahmsweise einmal so ein paar
werkzeuge weil er so viel eisen
ich glaube ist doch kein stoner ich hab'
ich dachte es wäre einer gewesen weil
die zombies in so einer schnellen
frequenzkamm aber das war keine okay gut
ich habe sachen gemacht haben ist
einfach ein echtes auto passt alles drin
gegner jäger fetten hohen alter erwartet
dass zwei diamanten gefunden findet man
noch alle weil dann kann ich mir noch
eine rose machen dann kannst du dir noch
erhöhen
diese machen dann macht er noch eine
hose obwohl an schärfe drei glaube ich
erst mal ein bisschen sinnvoller wäre
von den von den schwertern herald na ja
es stimmt stimmt auf jeden fall als ich
das mal auf schärfe drei wien weil
rüstungs mäßig sind wir sind wir absolut
oben weil die meisten nachfolgerin und
richtig hätten zu können ist mir ein
bisschen wichtiger als als irgendwie ja
mal wenn man mit einem schärfen vier
schwert kommt dann kannste knicken dann
dann bringt ihr bringt ja auch nix mehr
so das hörst du gar nicht mehr geld ich
bin ziemlich weit weg ich bin noch
ziemlich weit unten drunter heutiges
gucken dass ich dann nach einem weg
wieder zurück finde ich schade machen
was soll ich denn machen wenn ich noch
ein bisschen
es wird sonst langweilig findet ja ich
wollte uns jetzt also links links genau
dass ich wollte mir diese apfel kacke
besser die goldenen äpfel ja genau
ja die sind gut also die normalen golden
apple weil opel die sind ein bisschen
teurer baum der gold blöcke für elke
krystufek keine ahnung von minecraft du
willst du dein kind wird die gewinnerin
und wenn ich mit schere irgendwie sowas
abfälle kriege ich dann auch äpfel weil
ich das einzige was sie
krieges blätter ich weiß es nicht also
die s bahn einfach random ich denke
einfach wenn du halt die blätter
irgendwie platt macht ob es auch mit mit
dingen ist sie nicht ich gehe jetzt mal
an redstone abzubauen weil das ihr mega
gut xp bringt und wir dass japan gedacht
am besten alle ärzte ab und es ein
bisschen doof dass wieder in unsere
alten dingsbums einfach alles hat mühe
haben liegen lassen
guckt mal ein energie ohne spaß ich kann
nur wiederholen ich glaube wirklich die
anderen haben mittlerweile einen respekt
vor uns entwickelt und das ist auch gut
so
ich würde mich damit nicht zu weit aus
dem fenster lehnen du weißt verliebt und
guckt einfach
es liegt nicht an gold ewig an den ecken
hier bin ich runter gekommen cool ist es
gefunden habe ja ich bin ja schon auf
dann bleibe ich jetzt die höhe habe ich
so vertun wird also irgendwie bei der
anderen in den höhlen das ist doch immer
mega die scheiße irgendwelchen
schluchten verein halben lover
irgendwelche richter hier irgendwelche
gegner david von minimal die mama es ist
erschreckend wie gut das läuft bei uns
ja ich hätte es auch gar nicht gedacht
aber ich glaube wir bald zu einer sein
pessimismus herangegangen gerade
deswegen läuft das ja nur ich kriegte
einfach keine äpfeln
ich habe hier zehn millionen blätter
aber ich kriege keine äpfel und ich
glaube ich sind jetzt einfach mal ein
wald an
so wurde auch mal empfohlen dass es auch
mal sinnvoll wäre ein bisschen tiefer
also auf 11 zum beispiel durch die
gegend zum einen weil ich dadurch
vielleicht ihr diamanten mitbekommen die
über mir sind deswegen habe ich jetzt
mal auf elf aus meine lieblingsschuhe
ist eigentlich 13 fürs tritt main
aber wir können auch mal drei zu
benutzen das witzige ist ja das hätte
negative kommentare geschrieben luca
dein erstes video war ja wie finde ich
am schnellsten durch die taktik die
damals heftig funktioniert ich weiß ja
immer noch funktioniert das schon wieder
schwinden öle oder sommer party machen
weil die chance sehr sehr hoch ist das
man in lava fällt ja doch ich mache
jetzt einfach mal ein feuerzeug und fand
ihren walter ne du machst das mahnmal
das mal ruhig du kannst auch übrigens
mit dem feuerzeug natürlich im voraus
wenn du ob smeekes ja die anzünden und
dann ist das fleisch direkt gebraten ist
auch sinnvoll
ich möchte am besten irgendwie sorgen so
einen riesigen wald anzünden irgendwie
solche zeichen leiste sonst halten so
hey wir haben feuerzeuge damit es genau
waren ein ganzer wald abbrennt nur das
wäre auf jeden fall findet sogar wieder
durch die gegend die ja auch immer am
nikolaus hatte das paar bei gesagt du
kannst du das feuerzeug zündete mal
deine schwester an die opel schwester
saab zimmerantenne da selbst angezündet
erstmal vom wasser einmal gebrauch
gemacht da super duper weiße bei dir
merkt man einfach da ist wirklich das
knowledge start ganz großes zu mit jedem
einzelnen fall zu sein
pauli makkaroni wo bin ich hier gelandet
das ist ja das ist ja das ist ja nett du
das ist ja das ist ja grandios ja nur
der wald brennt
weißt du dir auch einfach bei jedem
immer wenn ich sehe immer wenn am abend
alle aufregen jemand geht auf dem server
jemand joint nach wenn dir aufnehmen
kunden einfach niemand nach dass
entweder entweder keine oder was weiß
ich alles brennt geht aus als brent ich
habe einfach die ganzen wald angezündet
ist das total toll gemacht ich bin
glaube ich hier schon fast am also hier
ist mir zu gefährlich das ist hier ich
mir da ist das was wir machen
warum hast du eigentlich aber etwas
produktives machst du schon mal nebenbei
oder du ich habe uns grad wasser einmal
gemacht ich weiß animations- machen soll
dazu wächst gerade ich glaub ich auch
nochmal strip mal nach unten
das könnte das kannst du natürlich tut
es mir vielleicht gar kein und ich
schaue auf die uhr
foto schoss das ist das ist es wichtig
ja weil man ja haben uns in der letzten
folge haben uns ja vergangen an an der
zeit wäre es nicht zeit einfach mal
heftig durchgenommen kann man einfach 20
sekunden überzogen nicht sogar noch mehr
wenn das internet tv ist einfach einfach
asozial auf irgend wo finde ich
natürlich müsste so ein projekt regeln
geben weil wenn ja wenn man ja andauernd
überzieht oder die folgen seien noch
jemand will dann hat man ja unfaire
vorteile
also wir haben ja anfangs zum beispiel
sehr sehr wenig dieses zeit
zeitkontingent ausgereizt und mein gott
die familie zombie ohne kopf ist das
nämlich in folge aus
sexy finden muss ich sagen also die zeit
zu verbringen über das auf der einzige
moment in dem ich mit menschen reden in
meinem leben
was also spricht ja niemand mit mir bin
ein sozialer [ __ ] und in folge
hast du einen bogen
warum da oben ist so ein heftig
ausgerüstet allerdings nicht abgibt
heftig ep das ist das ist glaube ich
bleibe wo ich bin oder dass ich seit ich
sie zeigt gott dieser tonja bemerkbaren
schlepper an erinnert mich ein bisschen
an seine mutter gerade war schon in von
den proportionen einfach eckig muss muss
er muss man auch mit schlimmer werfen so
ich freue mich jetzt hoch was eigentlich
extrem dumm aussah runterkommt 99 haben
wir viele geschrieben kinos läuft auch
mal auf 9 durch die gegend denn auf 9 ab
ich schon dinge erlebt davon träumen ich
muss nachher hoch in der neuen horex gar
nicht habe da so viel umgesetzt an licht
alles mögliche was immer immer wenn du
redest fällt mir als auch dass mein
unterleib zittert du bist wenn du redest
zittert mein unterleib ich brauch neue
fackeln neue neue fackeln was ich weiß
noch gar nicht was was ich genau hier
glauben macht das ist also das ist
bisher mein komisch strip mining ski
stehen
so brandneu von giorgio armani wo bist
du eigentlich bist aber mittlerweile
echt somit am besten ausgerüstet also
ich will mich als nicht überheblich
könnte selber schreiben wer zum
zeitpunkt dieser aufnahme bessere sachen
hat aber bedenken in der nächsten
episode dabei ist ein durchgehender
fortschritt bis wir alle irgendwann
sogar ausgesetzt sind dass wir dann
einfach ich bin mir ja irgendwie ich
habe das so die ganze zeit unguten
gefühl dass wir echt so einen richtig
schönen tod
hast du hast du das studio aufgebaut
oder was das mit dem kabel stoney an der
seite der seite krabbelt weil dann
könnte das ja ins porno ist oder wenn
kabel stone da ist eine wand doch
irgendwie ja doch das okay okay gut habe
sich auf 60 ausgemacht dass es hier auch
zu gemacht
ist ja auch so andere hoppel ist oder
was soll ich jetzt gerade eben erwähnen
ich wollte ja du bist schön und sexy
genau richtig manchmal manchmal
kommentiere ich so einen einen einem
quartett zusammen das ist nicht mehr ist
nicht mehr nicht mehr von ich bin jetzt
mein top-level level auf höhere 11 finde
ich aber nicht sogar irgendwie das ist
das ja wohl 13 fand ich bisher auch
immer am besten aber ich habe gerade so
viel wir haben übrigens unterschiedlich
protected das mache ich mal gleich geld
ja das wäre vielleicht eine gute idee
dass wir hier nicht rum stehen lassen
und am ende all unsere ärzte wechselt
aber gab mache ich erstmal schule mit
einem richtig guten schutz
ich brauche auch einfach mal redstone
bringt schon erfahrungen dort
funktionieren der lukas tritschler
comdirect lava entgegen aber wirklich
direkt es ist ich hab so viel crêpes in
meinem inventar dieses lapislazuli das
einfach noch nie jemand in minecraft
gebraucht hat ich glaube ich jetzt auf
dieser über die durch charakter 11,2
eisen stiefel sind dezent am stiefel ich
glaube einfach so mit laube obwohl ich
eine minute 14 das heißt keine 14
minuten 22 grad
richtig ich glaube ich glaube dann würde
ich vorschlagen dass wir diese episode
an dieser stelle auch beenden
ich finde ich finde aber ich schütze
noch schneiden unsere tue ist das
vielleicht würde ich bin dann sitze ich
dir gleich muss mich noch holen gehen
also wird das projekt von dem server
damit ist die folge zu ende
das will werbung gefallen hatte sind
weiterhin produktiv und geben uns die
höchste menge piesau team um produktiv
hashtag konsums